son tay 102 habitants fermiers pour la
plupart pas un seul magasin pas d'école
à 50 km au sud est de la ville de
hambourg en basse saxe
anciennement en allemagne de l'est ce
petit village au milieu de nulle part
était quelque peu assoupi jusqu'au jour
où début novembre
on n'y a vu arriver des centaines de
réfugiés
beaucoup de gens ici ont 80 85 1 la
dernière fois qu'ils ont vu des gens de
couleur c'était lors du débarquement des
américains en 1945 à surmonter le choc
était totale derrière ces murs entassés
dans des hangars
ils sont aujourd'hui près de 700
réfugiés de 25 nationalités différentes
mais notre caméra n'est pas bienvenu
place est ici par le gouvernement
allemand désespéré d'offrir un toit pour
l'hiver à des centaines de milliers de
migrants arrivés sur son sol
ils ne sont pas trop regardants one eye
but my life in germany quand j'ai mis
les pieds sur le sol allemand
j'ai senti que je commençais une vie
différente nouvelle parce qu'on s'est
senti comme comme des humains abdullah
originaire de damas ex gérant d'un
magasin zara a pris la route de l'exil
l'été dernier se retrouver en plein
milieu de nulle part dans la campagne
allemande ne semble pas le déranger
des tôles dos mais bo et fort qu'ils
nous ont dit que nous allons y rester
peut être trois mois alors peu importe
les conditions sort une fin peut-être
mais en attendant la population locale
n'a pas toujours bien réagi réfugiés pas
bienvenu pour est on lire sur les murs à
la proche du village avant que quelqu'un
ne camoufle pas sous une couche de
peinture
le maire a négocié ferme avec les
autorités pour réduire du tiers le
millier de nouveaux venus qui avait été
prévu
dhr est une des grandes villes de
l'ancienne allemagne de l'est
aujourd'hui célèbre pour avoir vu naître
le mouvement des guides à patriotes
européens contre l'islamisation de
l'occident depuis un an et manifestent
tous les lignes le problème souvent
c'est que ce sont des musulmans et qu'il
ya beaucoup de problèmes à travers le
monde à cause des musulmans par exemple
terrorisme à paris tous les menti nous
avons une grand coeur riffs yens et
fiennes et fiennes est complètement fou
madame nettement et complète fou pour ce
fondateur de paix guide à la chancelière
a fait preuve d'une immense naïveté
madame merkel pensait pouvoir compter
sur ses partenaires européens le
danemark la suède l'angleterre les pays
d'europe de l'est
mais ils ont tous fermé leurs portes et
maintenant elle est tout seul
il est vrai que la chancelière angela
merkel en a surpris plusieurs le 25 août
dernier quand elle a annoncé que
l'allemagne ne refoulera plus les
demandeurs d'asile vers les pays par
lesquels ils sont entrés en europe
décision courageuse car elle lui a valu
bien des critiques des ténors de son
propre parti le courage moral d'angela
merkel en fait de risquer de perdre son
parti par rapport à une question
hautement morale c'est quand même
admirable
c'est suite à un débat à la télévision
où cette jeune palestinienne en attente
de statut a éclaté en sanglots
angela merkel aurait décidé d'ouvrir les
portes aux réfugiés syriens
il paraît qu'elle a pleuré quand elle a
justement vu
cette petite fille palestinienne donc un
choc émotionnel
déjà championne accueillant près de 40%
de tous les réfugiés sur le territoire
de l'union européenne l'allemagne
devient en 2015
une véritable terre promise début
décembre il était déjà un million à
avoir franchi sur compte hier l'arrivée
massive de réfugiés a mis à rude épreuve
les institutions d'accueil
c'est très difficile de donner tout ce
qu'ils ont besoin
cette porte parole du centre d'accueil
des réfugiés à berlin avoue être très
fatigué depuis des mois une foule
compacte se précise pour s'enregistrer
obtenir logement aides médicales et
financières
la plupart de ces hommes ont dormi sur
le trottoir en attendant l'ouverture des
portes
mais le centre na rive à traiter que 200
dossiers par jour
nous avons chaque jour plus de 1000 1500
personnes dans tout le campus
nous n'avons pas assez de logements pour
tout les réfugiés et en cherchant tout
berlin tous les jours fork entries pour
notre pays qui riche cinq cent mille
réfugiés ou même un million ce n'est pas
vraiment un problème économique ou
social c'est plus un problème de
logistique des pronostics pour ce
spécialiste
heureusement la société civile allemande
est particulièrement bien préparée à
l'accueil des réfugiés
car elle a dû après la guerre intégré 12
millions de déplacés venus de l'est
depuis une semaine thomass künzler
partage ce modeste de quatre pièces avec
six autres personnes venues de homs en
syrie
la mas 31 ans et trois enfants son beau
frère et sa petite miss l'allemagne
c'était leur rêve d'être avérée godet
ici c'est très bien je peux prendre ma
douche m'asseoir sur le divan manger
dans un endroit trop nous avons beaucoup
de problèmes à bâle 1 avec les réfugiés
c'est mieux aujourd'hui mais deux mois
avant c'était vraiment vraiment
difficile alors c'était une question
d'humanité pour moi question d'humanité
aussi et de courage pour la chancelière
angela merkel a dû avouer au congrès de
son parti lundi que même un pays comme
l'allemagne peut être dépassé par un si
grand nombre mais elle a refusé vous
fermez les portes réfugiés et s'est
mérité une ovation de neuf minutes
pendant ce temps dans le village de
sauter derrière ces murs en apparence
paisible
la situation a commencé à dégénérer sur
ces images amateurs qu'on nous a envoyé
les réfugiés protestent contre les
lenteurs administratives
ils en ont assez d'attendre ils se
sentent comme en prison abandonnée la
solitude au milieu de la campagne
allemande
ce n'est pas ce qu'ils espéraient en
quittant leur pays
vous savez cette vague de migrants elle
n'a pas eu d'impact négatif sur
l'économie allemande bien au contraire
les 15 milliards de dollars que devrait
coûter l'intégration de ces centaines de
milliers de réfugiés ont déjà commencé à
voir l'effet d'une mini relance
économique
et cette année pour la première fois
depuis 45 ans l'allemagne va équilibrer
son budget elle reste la première
économie d'europe